Hi, Sunny.
(audience clapping)
This cover just says like fall into me, also.
Do you feel that way?
Were you happy when you saw the cover?
I'm so happy, Drew.
Actually, the cover comes from a house
that I walk by every day
when I'm on Oak Bluffs.
And so I took a picture of it and I dream about that house.
I'm hoping one day someone will just gift it to me
out of nowhere and just put me in their will.
And I showed it to my editor and she's like,
"This is the house.
This is the house that the book is centered on."
And lo and behold, there's the cover.
Well I had no idea, I'm so glad I asked.
(Sunny laughs)
Yes. Yes.
Well, listen, you are the queen of hot topics.
And so we would love to hit some headlines with you.
Okay.
(audience clapping)
Let's do it.
First up we're talking about the key to relationships.
Everyone has a different idea on this topic.
And People reports that Saturday Night Live's
Pete Davidson, the resident cutie,
who's reportedly dating actress Phoebe Dynevor
says that his key is total and complete honesty.
He isn't into playing games.
He says that he's always upfront.
He says, "This is who I am. These are my issues.
Here's the whole deal, unfiltered."
Sunny, thoughts?
I've been married for almost 23 years.
Mazel Tov.
And I think Pete is really sexy, really cute,
that's why he gets all the hot girls.
All of them.
He's really funny, he's always really good.
Complete honesty? I think he's on the wrong track there.
I think when you first get into relationship,
you need to send your representative, right?
Because the person isn't really hooked yet.
So it's not about showing the good, the bad and the ugly.
It's just showing the good, it's showing the best,
it's showing what you could be.
It's trying to be the best version of yourself.
Then once you're in it, once the person's hooked,
once the person's in love-
Well, hon-
Then the works come out.
That's when the crazy comes out.
(audience laughter)
So you have me until then, Sunny,
but then the day breaks and you lose me.
Well listen,
it turns out that crazy's going to come out at some point,
so do you want it up front or in the back?
Yeah.
Back.
I just say, put a bow on it.
You know, present the best version of you
and then reveal slowly.
Right?
Yeah. Don't front load.
Because I tend to do a little bit of the crazy,
but I don't front load it.
Yeah. Don't front load the crazy.
Write that down for me.
(audience laughs)
Hey, Sunny, question.
You know, we're obsessed with "Bridgerton".
Did you watch it?
I'm obsessed.
I burn for Regé.
I burn for him.
I'll burn for-
Oh, good news.
Oh, Regé-Jean. Well, we have news on him.
Cosmopolitan reports, he is very much taken.
(Drew and Sunny gasp)
Yes. The Duke has a Duchess.
Her name is Emily Brown
and she's a copywriter and a part-time soccer player.
That's what we know so far.
Friends say that she's witty and great to be around.
And Emily and Regé-Jean are so together,
Drew, Sunny, they actually live together.
O M G.
(audience laughter)
So we're happy for them, right?
I mean, I'm still not getting over the fact
that he's not going to be on Bridgerton next year,
but at least I know that he's happy.
And she's nice?
(Ross and Drew laughing)
Yeah. I'm so happy for them.
(audience laughter)
That's so great.
I want your take on this, Sunny, though.
This is for my chicken fans out there
and I'm looking at Drew and Sunny.
(Drew clucks)
(Ross laughing)
AZ Big Media reports a café in Phoenix
recently held something called chicken yoga.
The Silkie chickens are allowed to just roam free
during the yoga session,
adding an extra layer of calm to the class.
And I think if you do yoga with chickens around,
you get extra strong breasts and thighs.
(audience laughter)
Sunny, what do you think of this story?
I love it.
I tend chickens. I have about 12 chickens right now.
I'm in the process of getting more.
I also have Silkies and Silkies are really calm
and they're really beautiful, beautiful souls.
And, you know, tending my chickens
is kind of like my happy place.
I actually just got these made for my eggs.
Oh, I am so jealous.
That is so cool.
Isn't it cool?
'Cause I hear that you also tend chickens,
so I'm going to have to have some of these made for you.
Oh, Sunny, I would be so honored.
I not only tend chickens,
my daughter, Olive taught Percy to swim this weekend.
Oh my gosh, wow!
Wait, sorry, can I just ask,
the chicken swims?
The chicken Percy is now an official swimmer.
And she just said, you know,
"I want to teach all the chickens to swim.
Gosh, forbid they ever get out
and they fall into some water,
they have to know how to take care of themselves."
And I thought she was, you know, I was like, okay.
And Percy is fully swimming,
and you would think that Percy would be like...
(Drew imitates a drowning chicken)
Yes.
Nope, calm as a cucumber, loved the whole process.
Ended up staying in the pool
and like, hanging out.
All this chicken talk,
I don't know what the cluck is going on.
(audience laughter)
Well, I know that we love Sunny
and thank you so much for joining us today.
I can't think of a better mind to pick than yours
and catch her on "The View"
and pick up your copy of "Summer on the Bluffs".
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music)